welcome to this video playing FM bingo
Bongo bingo Bongo I think I know this
guy actually mmm hi function that's my
checkmate on ok let's see if they let
see what happens yeah the london system
not exactly very exciting ok go far for
this line with bishop musics queen bee
three misha b six
hmm what about this here am I not
threatening 93 here the bishop moves 93
okay I can still take them or I'll start
with the with a stupid-looking move like
f6 to make sure that I can it looks very
stupid right 93 Bishop e7 but if I play
that and then 93 it's really just a pawn
for absolutely nothing okay let's do it
and maybe could have plexiform okay yeah
it's ugly but it's also a pawn right he
must take I guess otherwise I'll take e
to I mean night c4 or something and I'd
see to I can just take take it to and
maybe even a two after that so he takes
you three looks forced maybe Bishop c4
but that I can also just take
okay so mm I guess really just yeah just
take it come on and now I can also take
hom root Cajun you will take be six at
the end yeah I will I will end up with a
pawn that that's pretty clear but also
that's 95 ok take on a tool that's that
is just just securing the pawn long-term
ok so 96 he cannot is 97 may be
attacking attacking here ok I can take
on d4 as well
or back to before first em hard the same
I can I cannot really decide what's best
here the night probably has to move
anyway so on I'll do that now how do I
keep my material oh that's also night a
six maybe two to cover the c5 pawn yeah
maybe if it takes on c5 I can also take
with the night keeping the position
closed my higher that's okay that's
really okay this F 6 news is really ugly
but it really makes sure that this
Bishop on on h4 is absolutely doing
nothing we can play em yeah if he takes
I take with the night 97 I've rook c8
this is to cover the seven pawn in all
cases
and maybe I can prepare prepare
something like age 6 f5 to get the the
bishop back into the game it would also
improve his bishop but still
okay that's an interesting maybe trying
to try to take here and force me to take
with the pawn I can also maybe I should
be a 2 D 5 D 5c form yeah let's do that
d5 and okay well see for I can also take
a maybe why not why not take taking a
sir it's simple night x gives me a very
nice center and this is not bad from
structural point of view protecting
everything here it can play this now
okay improve improve the rook and
covering the porn here and maybe i can
drop back to c6 now attacking attacking
deform it was interesting to play Bishop
f4 earlier maybe I should have should
have done that
yeah 95 I will just take though I can
play Bishop f8 open next
and then this is hanging ok maybe maybe
you know if time morning maybe even if
I've don't see pain a big problem with
that check hmm ok r95 coming
b5 this night a six that's a bit
uncomfortable check check now 125
seconds that's that's the real issue
here
position is check quite quite nice
actually check
yeah I must be content with the draw
here probably chat six seconds is not
exactly mature and the position is of
course a draw okay this is a draw draw
checkered game drawn accepted here with
0009 okay now maybe I could have one on
time here some somewhere but the
position is of course totally dead ah
yeah the time the time I was I was not
quick enough here this is also a winning
position but to check the 20 seconds
really really irritated me yeah here f 3
f f 2 is is very easy ah yeah I'm still
not in good shape but then maybe I'm
coming back a bit him okay we hope you
enjoy it enjoyed the game thanks for
watching